So two years ago, we did an episode of our show from Penn State University. And one of our producers, Sarah Koenig, was in Paternoville. Paternoville is the tent village of students that springs up before every home football game there, not far from the statue of Joe Paterno, the coach, which is outside of Beaver Stadium. The students sleep out in the cold for a couple nights until the game so they get the best seats. This was right before they played Iowa State.
两年前，我们曾在宾夕法尼亚州立大学制作过一期节目。我们的制片人莎拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）当时就在帕特诺村（Paternoville）。帕特诺村是学生在每场主场橄榄球赛前自发组成的帐篷村，位置离比弗体育场（Beaver Stadium）外乔·帕特诺（Joe Paterno，该校教练）的雕像不远。为了能在比赛中抢到好座位，学生们会在寒风中露宿几晚直到比赛开始。这正是在他们对阵爱荷华州立大学之前。
Ladies and gentlemen in Paternoville! In 24 hours from now, we will already be up 40 points on Iowa! Hey [UNINTELLIGIBLE], what time is it? 10:43!
帕特诺村的女士们、先生们！从现在起24小时后，我们将领先爱荷华队40分！嘿[听不清]，现在几点了？10点43分！
And Michigan still sucks! Michigan-- [CROWD SINGS]
密歇根大学依然烂透了！密歇根——[人群歌唱]
This is just how much Penn State hates Michigan. They're not even playing Michigan the next day, and they still need to express how much they suck.
这就是宾夕法尼亚州立大学有多讨厌密歇根大学的程度。第二天他们甚至不是和密歇根大学比赛，但他们仍需要表达对对方的厌恶。
So after hanging out for a while with students who are telling her what football means to them, what Penn State means to them-- in both cases, a lot-- somebody asked Sarah--
在和那些向她诉说橄榄球对他们意味着什么、宾夕法尼亚州立大学对他们意味着什么——无论哪种情况，意义都很重大——的学生们相处一段时间后，有人问莎拉——
All right, so hang on, you've been firing questions. How are you feeling right Now you're sitting here around a bunch of drunk college kids.
好了，等一下，你一直在提问。你现在感觉如何？你正坐在一群喝醉的大学生中间。
You're like overwhelmed and surprised at our answers, because you--
你似乎被我们的回答弄得不知所措和惊讶，因为你……
I'm very surprised at how you genuinely enthusiastic you are about this school. I've never felt that way about any school-- what's surprising is that you guys aren't, like, cynical about the university at all. Like you're just into it.
我对你们对这所学校发自内心的热情感到非常惊讶。我从未对任何学校有过这种感觉——令人惊讶的是，你们对这所大学一点也不愤世嫉俗。你们就是完全沉浸其中。
There's nothing to be cynical about. They deal with every situation perfectly.
这里没什么好愤世嫉俗的。他们处理每一种情况都堪称完美。
They deal with every situation perfectly. That's how it looked in 2009. This girl's friends immediately tease her-- well, maybe not every situation. But basically, they agree.
他们处理每一种情况都堪称完美。在2009年看起来确实如此。这个女孩的朋友立即取笑她——好吧，也许不是每种情况。但基本上，他们表示赞同。
And if you know much about Penn State, you know why it is they feel that way. Coach Joe Paterno's grand experiment was to create a football program that would not only win games, the players would be the kind of students who take academics seriously. They'd be held accountable for going to class. "Success with honor" was its motto.
如果你对宾夕法尼亚州立大学了解较多，就会知道他们为何会有这种感觉。乔·帕特诺教练的伟大实验是建立一个不仅能赢球，而且球员都是认真对待学业的学生项目的橄榄球队。他们必须为上课负责。“成功与荣誉”是它的座右铭。
Back in 2009, when we did that show, I asked some students what made Penn State football special? And the answer was immediate, it was obvious.
早在2009年我们做那期节目时，我问过一些学生是什么让宾夕法尼亚州立大学的橄榄球与众不同？答案是直接且显而易见的。
Joe Paterno. Joe Paterno is what brings a lot of the-- it's like we pride ourselves on the things that Joe Paterno preaches.
乔·帕特诺。乔·帕特诺带来了很多……我们以乔·帕特诺所倡导的事情为荣。
Yeah, graduation rates is a big thing JoePa-- we have one of the highest-- I think we have the highest percent--
是的，毕业率是乔·帕特诺（JoePa）非常看重的一点——我们的比例是最高的之一——我想我们有最高的百分比——
82%--
82%——
Highest in the Big Ten, definitely.
绝对是“十大联盟”（Big Ten）中最高的。
They told me fans are supposed to keep a certain code of behavior toward their rivals. Players aren't allowed to gloat when they do well.
他们告诉我，球迷必须对对手保持某种行为准则。球员在表现出色时不允许幸灾乐祸。
Yeah, I'll never forget-- one of our players flipped into the end zone scoring a touchdown and got a 15-yard excessive celebration for that. Joe Paterno-- I mean, he's an old man, but he got down the sideline in that kid's face right away, saying, let's do sportsmanship. Exactly.
是的，我永远不会忘记——我们的一名球员在达阵得分后翻了个跟头，结果因为过度庆祝被罚了15码。乔·帕特诺——我的意思是，他是个老人，但他立刻冲到边线对着那孩子的脸，说，我们要讲体育精神。没错。
This is a point of pride for them. Our sports program does things right.
这是他们引以为豪的一点。我们的体育项目做得很好。
And this, all of this? This is what went to hell in the last two weeks with the charges that former Penn State Assistant Coach Jerry Sandusky sexually abused boys and Penn state officials knew. If you followed the news even a little bit, you've heard the charges from the grand jury's report. Most damning, Assistant Coach Mike McQueary says that back in 2002, he walked in on Sandusky in the locker room shower-- the grand jury report doesn't use the word "raping," but that's plainly what they're talking about-- raping a boy of about ten years old. McQueary then told Coach Paterno what he saw.
而这一切，所有这一切，在过去两周里随着前宾夕法尼亚州立大学助理教练杰瑞·桑达斯基（Jerry Sandusky）性虐待男童以及校方知情的指控而彻底崩塌。如果你哪怕稍微关注了一下新闻，你一定听过大陪审团报告中的指控。最令人震惊的是，助理教练迈克·麦奎里（Mike McQueary）称，早在2002年，他就在更衣室淋浴间撞见了桑达斯基——大陪审团报告中没有使用“强奸”这个词，但很显然他们说的就是这件事——正在强奸一个大约十岁大的男孩。麦奎里随后告诉了帕特诺教练他所看到的一切。
Paterno did not call the police, but testified that he instead told the head of the athletic program, Tim Curley, and Penn State administrator Gary Schultz. They did not go to the police either. Instead, they banned Sandusky from bringing children into the locker room. That was it.
帕特诺没有报警，而是作证说他把这件事告诉了体育项目主管蒂姆·库利（Tim Curley）和宾夕法尼亚州立大学行政主管加里·舒尔茨（Gary Schultz）。他们也没有报警。相反，他们禁止桑达斯基带孩子进入更衣室。仅此而已。
Schultz testified that the university's president, Graham Spanier, approved that decision. Spanier, Schultz, and Curley had their own side of the story. They claim that they had not been told that Sandusky was actually having sex with a child. They didn't know that it went that far. The grand jury notes in its report that it did not find Tim Curley and Gary Schultz's testimony to be entirely credible.
舒尔茨作证说，大学校长格雷厄姆·斯帕尼尔（Graham Spanier）批准了该决定。斯帕尼尔、舒尔茨和库利有他们自己的说法。他们声称没有被告知桑达斯基实际上是在与一名儿童发生性关系。他们不知道事情已经严重到那种程度。大陪审团在报告中指出，他们认为蒂姆·库利和加里·舒尔茨的证词并非完全可信。
At Penn State, all this news has been like a bomb going off. As you probably heard, students rioted. And then everybody regrouped and tried to figure out what to make of it all.
在宾夕法尼亚州立大学，所有这些消息就像炸弹爆炸一样。正如你可能听说的，学生们发生了骚乱。然后每个人重新聚集，试图弄清楚这一切意味着什么。
Today on our radio program, we're going to spend the hour at Penn State, try to capture what it feels like there right now. And it is pretty extreme. It really is like people's world has been turned upside down. For context, later in the hour, we're going to hear some excerpts from our original 2009 program about Penn State, which people have been Tweeting and emailing about in the last two weeks, because it gives a sense of just how intense the culture of football is at Penn State. You see why everybody's feelings are running so high.
今天在我们的广播节目中，我们将花一小时的时间在宾夕法尼亚州立大学，试图捕捉现在那里的感受。情况非常极端。人们的世界真的被彻底颠覆了。为了提供背景，本小时稍后我们将播放我们在2009年制作的关于宾夕法尼亚州立大学的原始节目片段，过去两周人们一直在推特和邮件中谈论这些内容，因为它让人感受到宾夕法尼亚州立大学的橄榄球文化有多么强烈。你就会明白为什么每个人的情绪都如此高涨。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《This American Life》，由公共广播国际公司（PRI）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
["WE ARE PENN STATE" CHANT]
[高呼“我们是宾夕法尼亚州立大学”]
Act One. Say It Ain't So, Joe.
第一幕。说这不是真的，乔。
So our producer Sarah Koenig lives in State College, in the town that is the home of Penn State. And she says it has been a weird two weeks.
我们的制片人莎拉·柯尼格住在州立学院（State College），那是宾夕法尼亚州立大学的所在地。她说，过去两周非常诡异。
Here's what it's like to live here right now. 100,000 people are having the same conversation at the same time, everywhere they go. I'm overhearing them in line at the coffee shop, at my son's Taekwondo class, in a neighbor's driveway, as people walk down the sidewalk, talking on their cell phones. The weekly newsletter from my kids' school began, "In light of the truly tragic events," et cetera.
这就是现在住在这里的感觉。10万人在同一时间、在任何地方都在进行着同样的对话。我在咖啡店排队时、在我儿子的跆拳道课上、在邻居的车道上、当人们在人行道上边走边打手机时，都能听到他们在谈论。我孩子学校的每周通讯开头写道：“鉴于这一真正悲惨的事件”，等等。
And I'm having these conversations myself with everyone I know, and with many people I don't know. Like the guy behind the counter at Kinko's, who told me he didn't want to talk about it, and then we talked about it for 15 minutes. We can't stop. Because what happened here makes no sense.
我自己也在和认识的每一个人，以及许多我不认识的人进行这些对话。就像快印店（Kinko's）柜台后的那个人，他告诉我他不想谈论这件事，然后我们谈了15分钟。我们无法停止。因为发生在这里的事情根本说不通。
I can almost see how it happened. Almost.
我几乎能看出它是怎么发生的。几乎。
This is Nancy Weinreb. She's lived here for more than 30 years, worked in the university library. Her husband is a professor of organic chemistry, and she knows all the higher-ups involved in this thing. Maybe not well, but just socially, or knows people who knows them. The Spaniers, the Curleys, the Schultzes, She knows Mrs. Schultz.
这是南希·温雷布（Nancy Weinreb）。她在这里住了30多年，在大学图书馆工作。她丈夫是有机化学教授，她认识所有卷入此事的高层。也许谈不上很熟，只是社交上的认识，或者认识认识他们的人。斯帕尼尔一家、库利一家、舒尔茨一家。她认识舒尔茨太太。
I really-- it's hard. It's hard to understand, though. It's hard to understand how the leadership-- I mean, very good people and good men could not do what they should have done.
我真的……很难。但这很难理解。很难理解领导层——我的意思是，非常好的人和好男人，怎么会做不到他们本该做的事。
Because you do you think of them as good men.
因为你确实把他们视为好人。
Mmhm. I do.
嗯，是的。我是这样认为的。
And do you still?
那你现在还这么认为吗？
Well, I think they were terribly wrong. But yes, I guess I do. Yeah.
嗯，我认为他们大错特错了。但是的，我想我还是这么认为。是的。
Are you surprised to hear yourself say you still think of them as good men?
听到自己说仍然认为他们是好人，你感到惊讶吗？
Yes. Yes, I am surprised to hear myself think that, yes.
是的。是的，听到自己这么想，我也很惊讶，是的。
I've heard of a few people who compared this thing to 9/11, which seems melodramatic to me, but in one way, I do see the similarity. This feeling of the whole place suddenly seeming unreal, off its axis. Because how could good men turn out to be bad men? And obviously I don't mean Sandusky here. People have no ambivalence about Sandusky. The confusion is all about the guys around Sandusky, who appear to have let the alleged crimes go on.
我听过一些人把这件事比作9/11，这对我来说似乎有些矫情，但在某种程度上，我确实看到了相似之处。这种整个地方突然显得不真实、脱离了轨道的感觉。因为好人怎么会变成坏人呢？显然我在这里指的不是桑达斯基。人们对桑达斯基没有矛盾心理。困惑全在于桑达斯基身边的人，他们似乎放任了这些所谓的罪行继续发生。
I met Nancy Weinreb through her son, Michael Weinreb. Michael is a sportswriter. He wrote a book all about football in the 1980s, a large chunk of which is about Penn State, actually. And he's a columnist for this new online magazine called Grantland. He's been writing great columns since the story erupted two weeks ago. At least half a dozen people told me about them. They're circulating like crazy here. Because he's a local, and he's just as disoriented as we are.
我是通过南希·温雷布的儿子迈克尔·温雷布（Michael Weinreb）认识她的。迈克尔是一名体育记者。他写了一本关于20世纪80年代橄榄球的书，其中很大一部分其实是关于宾夕法尼亚州立大学的。他是新在线杂志《Grantland》的专栏作家。自从两周前这件事爆发以来，他一直在写很棒的专栏。至少有六个人向我提起过这些文章。它们在这里流传得很疯狂。因为他是本地人，他和我们一样感到迷茫。
In one of the columns, he wrote, "I can't add a lot to what's been written about the facts of the burgeoning scandal at Penn State, except to tell you how strange it feels to type the phrase 'burgeoning scandal at Penn State.' I know that I'm too emotionally attached to the situation to offer any kind of objective take, though I don't think I realized how emotionally attached I was until this occurred."
在其中一篇专栏文章中，他写道：“对于宾夕法尼亚州立大学日益严重的丑闻事实，我无法在已有的报道上增加太多内容，除了告诉你，打出‘宾夕法尼亚州立大学日益严重的丑闻’这句话感觉有多么奇怪。我知道我对这种情况情感上投入太多，无法提供任何客观的看法，尽管在事情发生之前，我并没有意识到自己投入得有多深。”
In another column, he tells a story his mom told him last weekend. Quote, "I think it explains as well as anything how jarring this is for a community that has never experienced such a complete and utter shock to its system. My mother's friends-- let us call them the Xes-- are cordial with Graham Spanier, the university president who lost his job a few days before. So last week, Mrs. X baked a coffee cake, got in her car, sweet-talked the security guard stationed in the Spaniers' driveway, and dropped it off at the front door. It was not meant to condone anything Spanier had done. It was merely a way of acknowledging-- well, honestly, I don't know what the hell it was meant to acknowledge, and the Xes didn't, either. But it's just something you do in small towns, isn't it?" Unquote.
在另一篇专栏中，他讲了一个他母亲上周末告诉他的故事。引述：“我想这最好地解释了对于一个从未经历过如此彻底和完全的系统性冲击的社区来说，这件事有多令人震惊。我母亲的朋友——我们称他们为X夫妇——与格雷厄姆·斯帕尼尔交情不错，就是那位在几天前丢了工作的大学校长。所以上周，X太太烤了一个咖啡蛋糕，坐进车里，对驻守在斯帕尼尔家车道的保安说了好话，把蛋糕留在了前门。这并不是为了宽恕斯帕尼尔所做的任何事。这仅仅是一种致意的方式——好吧，老实说，我不知道它到底意味着什么，X夫妇自己也不知道。但这只是小城镇里你会做的事情，不是吗？”引述结束。
I understand that. What do you do when a massive child rape scandal hits your town? So I called Michael up. We met last Friday at the giant vigil in front of Old Main, Penn State's admin building. Students organized it to recognize sex abuse victims. We talked about, what else, Penn State football.
我理解这一点。当一场大规模的儿童强奸丑闻冲击你的小镇时，你该怎么办？所以我给迈克尔打了电话。上周五我们在老主楼（Old Main，宾夕法尼亚州立大学的行政大楼）前的巨大守夜活动中见了面。学生们组织了这次活动来纪念性虐待受害者。我们谈论了——还能谈什么——宾夕法尼亚州立大学的橄榄球。
I mean, I do watch all the games. Like, we went on our honeymoon in Greece this year, and I found myself following the football game on my cell phone at 10 o'clock at night, feeling like an idiot for doing it. Sitting in a hotel lobby in Athens, and I'm following a football game on my cell phone.
我的意思是，我确实看所有的比赛。比如，今年我们去希腊度蜜月，我发现自己在晚上10点用手机查看橄榄球比赛，觉得自己像个白痴。坐在雅典的一家酒店大堂里，我用手机追踪一场橄榄球比赛。
It was freezing. We walked to his friend Ryan's car. Michael lives in New York City now, and he'd come back here to go to Saturday's game, and to just be here, to see what it felt like to be back home. He grew up in town, went to Penn State, wrote for the school paper. And he's quick to issue the following disclaimer. He is fully aware that this whole ordeal isn't about him. It's about little kids who were hideously abused, and how it affected him personally, obviously, that does not matter one way or the other.
天气很冷。我们走到他朋友瑞安的车旁。迈克尔现在住在纽约市，他回到这里是为了参加周六的比赛，也只是为了待在这里，看看回到家乡是什么感觉。他在镇上长大，就读于宾夕法尼亚州立大学，为校报写过稿。他很快提出了以下免责声明。他完全意识到这一切并不是关于他。这是关于那些受到可怕虐待的小孩，而这对他个人产生的影响，显然，无论如何那都不重要。
And yet, like so many people from State College, he's been deeply freaked out ever since he heard about this thing.
然而，就像州立学院的许多人一样，自从听说这件事以来，他一直深受震动。
It doesn't make any sense. It just doesn't compute. So that's a lot of what I was talking about my parents, too, is just how that part of it-- it just doesn't-- it just goes against everything that you thought you understood, you know? I just-- I don't know. I keep waking up every morning and thinking that it's a dream. It still doesn't seem real. I was expecting to come up here and it to feel different in some way, but it's still the same place, you know? Like I don't even know why I'm here, or what I'm supposed to be writing, or what I'm supposed to be doing at this point.
这根本说不通。这根本计算不出结果。所以，我和父母谈论的很多内容也都是关于这一部分的——这根本……这违背了你所认为自己理解的一切，你知道吗？我只是……我不知道。我每天早上醒来都以为这是一场梦。它仍然显得不真实。我原本期待来到这里时会有某种不同的感觉，但这依然是同一个地方，你知道吗？就像我甚至不知道我为什么在这里，或者我应该写什么，或者此时此刻我应该做些什么。
We drove over to the football stadium to see if kids were camping out before the game at Paternoville. There was almost no one there. It was too cold. Just two tents were still up, and one had blown over backwards, like a helpless beetle.
我们开车去橄榄球场，看看孩子们是否在比赛前露宿在帕特诺村。那里几乎没有人。太冷了。只有两个帐篷还立着，其中一个像一只无助的甲虫一样向后吹倒了。
The three of us, Michael, Ryan, and I, ended up talking until 1:30 in the morning. Like I said earlier, you just can't stop. For my part, I'm basically rubbernecking, upset and appalled by the crash. Michael, though, it's like he's in the pile-up. His memory is tangled up with this mess. With Paterno, with football. He's here to figure out if he can untangle it. He's worried his past, his childhood, might be contaminated by all this stuff.
我们三个——迈克尔、瑞安和我——最终一直聊到凌晨1点半。正如我之前所说，你就是无法停止。就我而言，我基本上是在看热闹，对这场车祸感到不安和震惊。但迈克尔，他就像是在车祸现场。他的记忆与这团乱麻纠缠在一起。与帕特诺纠缠，与橄榄球纠缠。他在这里是为了弄清楚他是否能理清这一切。他担心他的过去，他的童年，可能会被所有这些事情污染。
And so a lot of the good memories I have, you know, father-son stuff that-- I'm starting to sound like it's Field of Dreams or something all of a sudden. But I don't know how that stuff changes. I don't know if it changes, you know? When I think of, like, Penn State beating Nebraska in 1982, and like my dad lifting me on his shoulders, because I couldn't see anything, because everybody was standing up-- and then the last play of the game-- that was like one of the few times I've seen my dad actually shout and get excited about something.
所以，我拥有的许多美好回忆，你知道，父子之间的那些事情……我开始听起来像是《梦幻成真》（Field of Dreams）之类的电影了。但我不知道这些事情如何改变。我不知道它是否会改变，你知道吗？当我想到1982年宾夕法尼亚州立大学击败内布拉斯加大学，就像我父亲把我举在他的肩膀上，因为我什么也看不见，因为每个人都站着——然后是比赛的最后一球——那是我见过父亲真正为某事大喊大叫、感到兴奋的少数几次之一。
But I don't know. I don't know how it will affect all that stuff. Because Joe Paterno is there. He was an integral part of all that stuff.
但我不知道。我不知道它会如何影响所有这些事情。因为乔·帕特诺在那里。他是所有这些事情中不可或缺的一部分。
I don't know if you noticed how easily he referenced that Penn State-Nebraska game from 1982. I heard Michael do this over and over. Football is how he marks time, an organizing principle for his life. He remembers watching the Sugar Bowl in 1979 in the family room when he was 6, and then going outside in the snow with his next door neighbor and replaying the game so Penn State would win. "To this day," he wrote one of his recent columns, "When I try to recall the combination of my gym locker, or a friend's birthday, or the license plate of my rental car, I think in terms of uniform numbers. It's not 31-17-03. It's Shane Conlan, Harry Hamilton, Chip La Barca."
我不知道你是否注意到他是多么自然地提到了1982年那场宾夕法尼亚州立大学对阵内布拉斯加大学的比赛。我听到迈克尔一遍又一遍地这样做。橄榄球是他标记时间的方式，是他生活的组织原则。他记得6岁时在客厅看1979年的糖碗（Sugar Bowl），然后和隔壁邻居去雪地里重演比赛，这样宾夕法尼亚州立大学就能赢。“直到今天，”他在最近的一篇专栏文章中写道，“当我试图回想我的健身房储物柜密码、朋友的生日或我的租赁汽车车牌时，我都会用球衣号码来思考。不是31-17-03。而是肖恩·康兰（Shane Conlan）、哈里·汉密尔顿（Harry Hamilton）、奇普·拉·巴尔卡（Chip La Barca）。”
Penn State played Miami here, and they got killed. And I think that was the last game before September 11. For some reason, I just marked it-- I remember going to the first game, I think it was the first game after September 11, when they played Wisconsin.
宾夕法尼亚州立大学在这里对阵迈阿密大学，结果被彻底击溃了。我想那是9/11事件前的最后一场比赛。出于某种原因，我只是标记了它……我记得去看了第一场比赛，我想是9/11之后对阵威斯康星大学的那场。
I find this a little crazy, and so does he, that he's bookended September 11 with Penn State football games. And he will, no doubt, mark this thing happening now with tomorrow's game against Nebraska.
我觉得这有点疯狂，他自己也这么认为，他竟然用宾夕法尼亚州立大学的橄榄球比赛来界定9/11事件的前后。毫无疑问，他也会用明天对阵内布拉斯加大学的比赛来标记现在发生的这件事。
Here's what he wrote in another column. "I do not believe Paterno deserves our sympathy right now, and in fact, I walked around State College this weekend supremely pissed off that he did not live up to the standards he would like us to believe he set for himself. And I was not alone in that sentiment. And yet when I saw those televised shots of his house on McKee Street, something caught in my throat. The conditioned response to a man I've been raised to believe is the moral arbiter of our community."
他在另一篇专栏文章中写道：“我不认为帕特诺现在值得我们同情，事实上，这个周末我在州立学院走来走去，对未能达到他希望我们相信他为自己设定的标准感到无比愤怒。而这种情绪并非我一人独有。然而，当我看到电视上播出他在麦基街（McKee Street）的房子的镜头时，我的喉咙里有什么东西哽住了。这是一个我从小被灌输要相信是我们的社区道德仲裁者的人的条件反射。”
And of course, Michael's not alone in this. In State College, confusion has seeped into everyone's house. You can't believe it happened, or that it happened the way they're saying it happened in the grand jury report. There must be something we don't know, some key moment, some key insight, some key fact that will make it add up.
当然，迈克尔并不是唯一有这种感觉的人。在州立学院，困惑已经渗入了每个人的家中。你无法相信这件事发生了，或者说你无法相信它竟然是以大陪审团报告中描述的那样发生。一定有什么我们不知道的事情，某个关键时刻，某个关键见解，某个关键事实，能让这一切讲得通。
So thousands and thousands of people here, including me, are turning over theories. A former State College cop told me the other day, the football program is run like the mafia, and Paterno is the godfather. This cop had had suspicions about Sandusky for years, saw him hug a Little League kid a little too enthusiastically one time, and had seen him hanging around high school sports events, and had actually spoken to Sandusky about it, asked him, why exactly was he there? So this cop things Paterno and all the others around the football program must've known for a long time.
所以这里成千上万的人，包括我在内，都在琢磨各种理论。一位前州立学院警察前几天告诉我，橄榄球项目就像黑手党一样运作，帕特诺就是教父。这位警察多年来一直对桑达斯基有怀疑，曾有一次看到他太热情地拥抱了一个小联盟的孩子，也曾看到他在高中体育赛事附近转悠，并实际上就此事质问过桑达斯基，问他到底为什么在那里？所以这位警察认为帕特诺和橄榄球项目周围的所有人肯定早就知道了。
Paterno obviously has a lot of defenders, too, or at least people looking very hard for a reason not to condemn him. I met a football fan slash Penn State Law student named Chris who said he and all his friends in the law program are very skeptical of the grand jury report. Grand jury reports are supposed to be one-sided, he said, and there are so many inconsistencies.
显然，帕特诺也有很多捍卫者，或者至少是那些非常努力地寻找理由不去谴责他的人。我遇到了一个既是橄榄球迷又是宾夕法尼亚州立大学法学院学生的克里斯，他说他和他在法学院的所有朋友都对大陪审团的报告非常怀疑。他说，大陪审团报告理应是片面的，而且里面有太多的不一致之处。
It could be complete reversal. We may find out, hypothetically, that Tim Curley and Gary Schultz are telling the truth, and it's in fact Mike McQueary who is lying.
这可能是完全的颠倒。我们可能会发现，假设蒂姆·库利和加里·舒尔茨说的是实话，而实际上迈克·麦奎里在撒谎。
And this woman, Lori, an alum and Paterno devotee who I met at the vigil last Friday-- she can't believe Paterno would have just let this go.
还有这位女士，洛丽，一位上周五我在守夜活动中遇到的校友和帕特诺的忠实信徒——她无法相信帕特诺会就这么放任不管。
Maybe, maybe he was told that things were being followed up on, and he was under the impression that they were, but they weren't.
也许，也许有人告诉他事情正在跟进，他以为事情正在处理中，但实际上并没有。
I've heard people blame the cops for being in collusion with Penn State. I've heard cock-a-mamie theories, like people saying, this is all because the Pennsylvania AG wanted to take down Spanier, who fought publicly with the governor over funding earlier this year. The governor, who used to be the AG. I've heard that Paterno promoted Mike McQueary so he'd keep his mouth shut. A lawyer in town told me he blamed the lawyers, said Penn State's lawyers covered this whole thing up.
我听到有人指责警察与宾夕法尼亚州立大学勾结。我听到过各种荒谬的理论，比如有人说，这一切都是因为宾夕法尼亚州总检察长想搞垮斯帕尼尔，因为斯帕尼尔今年早些时候曾公开与州长就资金问题发生争执。那位州长曾经是总检察长。我听说帕特诺提拔迈克·麦奎里是为了让他闭嘴。镇上的一位律师告诉我他责怪律师，说宾夕法尼亚州立大学的律师掩盖了整件事。
My friends Kim and Will moved here from Seattle about a decade ago. Our daughters are friends. Will's a bioengineer at Penn State.
我的朋友金（Kim）和威尔（Will）大约十年前从西雅图搬到这里。我们的女儿是朋友。威尔是宾夕法尼亚州立大学的生物工程师。
I'm one that embraces denial as much as the next person.
我是那种和任何人一样乐于拥抱否认的人。
Denial is a big theory here, too. Not just on an institutional level, on a personal level. That some combination of Paterno, Curley, Schultz, Spanier simply could not, or would not, believe such grotesque crimes were happening in their locker rooms.
否认在这里也是一个重要的理论。不仅仅是在机构层面，在个人层面也是如此。帕特诺、库利、舒尔茨、斯帕尼尔的某种组合根本不能，或不愿相信在他们的更衣室里正在发生如此令人作呕的罪行。
There are so many reasons to tell yourself that you're not exactly sure. So you're telling yourself you have to be so sure, and you're not 100% sure, and so, well, it wasn't exactly illegal, or I don't need to do this, I only need to go this far, or somebody else is going to do it, or maybe he didn't see what he thought he saw, and things like that. There's so much incentive to try to want it to not be true. And then you just kind of wish it away.
有太多理由告诉自己你并不完全确定。所以你告诉自己你必须非常确定，但你并没有百分之百确定，所以，嗯，它并不完全违法，或者我不需要做这个，我只需要做到这一步，或者别人会去做，或者也许他没看到他以为自己看到的东西，诸如此类。人们有太大的动力去试图想要它不是真的。然后你就只是想把它驱逐出脑海。
The crux of the riddle for a lot of people is, did Mike McQueary really tell Joe Paterno and other university officials exactly what he's now saying he saw? That is, Jerry Sandusky in the shower, raping a boy who looked to be about ten years old? McQueary says there was no ambiguity about what he told them. They, of course, say that it was never clear to them the shower incident was of a, quote, "sexual nature."
对许多人来说，谜题的核心在于，迈克·麦奎里是否真的告诉了乔·帕特诺和其他大学官员他现在所说的他所看到的？也就是说，杰瑞·桑达斯基在淋浴间强奸了一个看起来大约十岁大的男孩？麦奎里说他告诉他们的话没有任何歧义。而他们当然说，淋浴事件属于“性性质”这件事对他们来说从来都不清楚。
So how do you square that? I've heard people say they believe that maybe McQueary didn't quite get the information out. There he is, sitting on the sofa across from Paterno, a football legend, his mentor, a 70-something-year-old man, a Catholic-- and is he really going to paint the picture? The shower, a little boy, ugh. Like one of my friends said, it could be that something got lost in the telling.
那么你如何调和这一点呢？我听到有人说他们相信也许麦奎里没有把信息传达清楚。他当时坐在帕特诺对面的沙发上，帕特诺是一个橄榄球传奇，是他的导师，一个70多岁的老人，一个天主教徒——他真的会描绘出那种画面吗？淋浴间，一个小男孩，呃。就像我的一个朋友说的，可能在讲述的过程中漏掉了什么东西。
Kim of Kim and Will is a psychotherapist. She thinks Spanier, the university president, got all turned around in his decision-making, partly because of the closed circle he lived in, where administrators talk mostly to other administrators. Spanier has said he never knew about the sexual assaults. Spanier, by the way, is also a family therapist.
金（Kim）是一名心理治疗师。她认为大学校长斯帕尼尔在决策上完全糊涂了，部分原因是他生活在一个封闭的圈子里，行政人员主要只和其他行政人员交流。斯帕尼尔曾说他从来不知道这些性侵事件。顺便说一句，斯帕尼尔也是一名家庭治疗师。
Do you feel like, at the end of the day, he knew or he didn't know the particulars? Spanier?
你觉得最终，他是知道还是不知道具体细节？斯帕尼尔？
I feel like he probably did. Yes, I do.
我觉得他大概是知道的。是的，我确实这么认为。
Mmhm. Does that make him a bad guy? Like, how do you get your head around that?
嗯。那这让他成为坏人了吗？你是怎么想通这一点的？
Maybe from being basically kind of a politician, right, for such a long time? That he might have lost touch with some sort of boots-on-the-ground morals that the rest of us can live with? And he's dealing with large groups of people, and large sums of money, and I could imagine him confusing his duty to the university, and maybe even to the community, with his moral obligation to protect the innocent.
也许是因为他长期以来基本上是个政客，对吧？他可能已经与我们其他人能接受的那种脚踏实地的道德失去了联系？他在处理大群人，处理大笔资金，我可以想象他把对大学，甚至可能是对社区的责任，与保护无辜者的道德义务搞混了。
My friend Eileen grew up about an hour and a half from Penn State, in farming country. Eileen used to live across the street from McQueary's wife and mother-in-law, and she believes McQueary. That he told the higher-ups exactly what he saw, and they buried it.
我的朋友艾琳（Eileen）在距离宾夕法尼亚州立大学约一个半小时路程的农耕地区长大。艾琳过去住在麦奎里妻子和岳母的街对面，她相信麦奎里。相信他告诉了上层他所看到的真相，而他们掩盖了这一切。
In their world that kind of stuff didn't happen. And they couldn't deal with it. I mean, we were all having trouble dealing with the fact that it happened, and he was like a brother, I guess, in the football family, right? And so how can you deal with a family member doing something like that to kids?
在他们的世界里，那种事情是不会发生的。他们无法处理它。我的意思是，我们都在为这件事发生了这一事实而苦恼，而他就像橄榄球大家庭里的一个兄弟，对吧？所以你该怎么处理一个家庭成员对孩子做这种事呢？
Maybe what they said was, you know, it was one time-- they had a big boy meeting, and they sat him down, they had a sit-down, and they said you're not going to do this again, right? And he, of course, said, oh, yeah, yeah, no, not a thing, not an issue. And they used that to make themselves feel better, and for the greater good of all of Penn State. And I want to think they thought they were doing the right thing. I think JoePa did, right? That's a skewed vision, right? Of--
也许他们说的是，你知道，那只有一次——他们开了一个大男孩会议，让他坐下来，进行了一次谈话，说你不能再这样做了，对吧？而他当然说，哦，是的，是的，没别的事了，没问题了。他们利用这一点来让自己感觉好受些，并且是为了宾夕法尼亚州立大学的更大利益。我想他们以为自己在做正确的事。我想乔·帕特诺也是这么想的，对吧？那是一种扭曲的愿景，对吧？
Oh, you think they thought they were doing the right thing.
哦，你认为他们以为自己在做正确的事。
I think, at least-- and I'm not giving them an out here. But yeah, I think in that twisted world, he thought it'll serve more kids, and it'll be for the greater good if we just make this go away so that the football program can keep on doing what it does. And I'm not a-- oh, god. I'm not a football person.
我认为，至少……我不是在为他们开脱。但是的，我想在那个扭曲的世界里，他认为如果我们让这件事消失，以便橄榄球项目能继续做它所做的事情，这对更多的孩子有好处，是为了更大利益。我不是一个……噢，天哪。我不是一个橄榄球爱好者。
Were you just nervous to say that on tape?
你刚才在录音时是不是很紧张？
Yes!
是的！
Explain that. Why?
解释一下。为什么？
Where do we live, right? I think that's part of this whole thing. Imagine if me, who does not give a [BLEEP] about it, right? Really has some hesitation in this town. And because of the people in my life, some of the people in my life-- yeah, right? And I didn't even realize that, Sarah. That was involuntary. Really. That's ridiculous. It would be like me saying to my sister, who lives in rural Pennsylvania, yeah, I don't really care about the Steelers. I would not be invited for Christmas.
我们住在哪里，对吧？我想这是整个事情的一部分。想象一下如果像我这样根本不在乎的人，对吧？在这个小镇真的有一些顾虑。而因为我生活中的人，我生活中的一些人……是的，对吧？我甚至没意识到这一点，莎拉。那是无意识的。真的。这很荒谬。这就像我对住在宾夕法尼亚州农村的妹妹说，是的，我真的不在乎钢人队（Steelers）。我绝对不会被邀请去过圣诞节。
On Saturday morning, Michael Weinreb and his parents and some family friends met, like they always do, at the chemistry building where Michael's father works, and then made the trek over to the football game.
周六早上，迈克尔·温雷布和他的父母以及一些家庭朋友像往常一样在迈克尔父亲工作的化学楼见面，然后徒步前往橄榄球比赛现场。
Where did the chicken coops used to be?
以前鸡舍在哪里？
The chicken coops, we'll pass by where the chicken coops used to be. It's where, there are field hockey fields over there now.
鸡舍，我们会经过鸡舍过去所在的地方。现在那里有曲棍球场。
But you'd have to make this walk up there, and you'd have to walk by these awfully--
但你得走那条路上去，你得经过这些糟糕的……
Well, it would smell, was part of the problem.
嗯，臭味是问题的一部分。
Terrible.
糟糕。
This exchange about the chicken coops was the sum total of Michael's communication with his father on the walk over, by the way, which Michael said was typical. His father is not a huge talker.
顺便说一句，关于鸡舍的这段对话是迈克尔在走过去的过程中与他父亲沟通的总和，迈克尔说这很典型。他父亲不怎么说话。
We headed up to Beaver Stadium, and again, things were more or less the same as any football Saturday. It was a beautiful day, people everywhere, looking happy.
我们前往比弗体育场，同样，情况和任何橄榄球周六大同小异。那是个美好的一天，到处都是人，看起来很高兴。
It just feels so normal right now. And it's odd.
现在感觉太正常了。而且很奇怪。
Is that comforting to you, or is it just weird?
这对你来说是安慰，还是只是觉得怪怪的？
It's just kind of weird. I feel like I should constantly be apologizing, you know?
只是觉得有点怪。我觉得我应该一直道歉，你知道吗？
To whom?
向谁？
To everybody. I mean, to the victims, obviously, to people who saw that stuff on TV the other night. It's just like this woman holding up that sign. That's kind of how I feel. You know?
向所有人。我的意思是，显然是向受害者，向那天晚上在电视上看到那些东西的人。就像那个举着牌子的女人一样。我差不多就是这种感觉。你知道吗？
What's the sign?
牌子上写什么？
It says, "To the victims, I apologize for Penn State."
上面写着，“致受害者，我为宾夕法尼亚州立大学道歉。”
Michael shoved a dollar into a box. There was another student collecting money for a child abuse charity, and fans were just shovelling money at them, jamming bills in there.
迈克尔往一个盒子里塞了一美元。还有另一个学生在为儿童虐待慈善机构募捐，球迷们只是不停地往里塞钱，把钞票塞进去。
So just to recap. This terrible story breaks open. People in State College are stunned. Then a couple days later, there's a riot-- a big, ugly retching of misplaced anger. And then two days after that, there's a vigil. A massive, solemn gathering that had the double benefit of calming the campus and looking good on the evening news. And then two days after that, there's a football game. And all of a sudden, that off-kilter feeling is gone. People are cheerful, excited. That's how it felt to me, anyway.
所以总结一下。这个可怕的故事爆发了。州立学院的人们惊呆了。然后几天后，发生了骚乱——一场巨大的、丑陋的、错位的愤怒呕吐。再过两天，举行了守夜活动。一场大规模、庄严的聚会，既安抚了校园，又在晚间新闻里显得体面。再过两天，有一场橄榄球比赛。突然间，那种失衡的感觉消失了。人们兴高采烈、兴奋不已。无论如何，我就是这种感觉。
And it occurs to me that maybe that's what happened to Paterno and those guys in the administration back when they first got wind of Sandusky's alleged crimes. Just give it some space, squint into the sun, go to a football game, and you can kind of forget about it.
我突然想到，也许这就是当初帕特诺和行政部门的那些人在第一次听到桑达斯基所谓的罪行时所发生的情况。只要给它一点空间，眯眼望向太阳，去看一场橄榄球比赛，你就能把这事儿给忘了。
The following morning, on Sunday, Michael told me it did feel different inside the stadium-- more subdued. Even the cheering was subdued.
第二天早上，周日，迈克尔告诉我体育场里的感觉确实不一样——更压抑了。即使欢呼声也很压抑。
It was just kind of quiet, even when it was loud. And it's like people were so tired of talking about the situation that they wanted to try to talk about the game, but then you start talking about the game, and you'd be like, how can we talk about the game? And then, you know, there was a moment in the fourth quarter where it was like, Penn State was down 17 to nothing, and they came back and made it 17-14, and then they got a defensive stop and got the ball back, and it was like-- I allowed myself like one moment where I kind of got excited, you know? It was kind of like, OK, I'm going to allow myself to get excited about football for two minutes here. Then they lost, and it was like, I don't care, you know? I didn't care that they lost, you know?
即使在声音很大时，也有一种安静的感觉。就像人们太厌倦谈论这件事了，他们想尝试谈论比赛，但当你开始谈论比赛时，你会想，我们怎么能谈论比赛呢？然后，你知道，第四节有一个时刻，宾夕法尼亚州立大学以0比17落后，他们反扑将比分追至14比17，然后他们防守成功拿回了球权，就像……我允许自己有那么一刻感到兴奋，你知道吗？就像是，好的，我允许自己在这里为橄榄球兴奋两分钟。然后他们输了，就像，我不在乎，你知道吗？我不在乎他们输了，你知道吗？
Have you had that feeling before?
你以前有过那种感觉吗？
Not quite like this, no. Yeah, see, that's the thing. I think a couple of my friends from college e-mailed me and they were like, I wish we would've won that, you know? And I was like, why? What difference does it make? It didn't matter. It just didn't matter.
不像这次这样，没有。是的，看，就是这样。我想我大学的几个朋友发邮件给我，他们说，我真希望我们能赢，你知道吗？而我说，为什么？那有什么区别？那根本不重要。就是不重要。
Did your parents have anything to say about it? Like that it felt different to them, or--
你父母有什么要说的吗？比如他们觉得感觉不一样了，或者——
Yeah, some guys in their row who were so drunk that they puked all over themselves. And I was like, that's weirdly like going to a funeral hammered, you know? It's like, just have some respect. First of all, it's a noon game. How do you get that drunk, you know? But--
是的，他们那一排有几个家伙醉得呕吐在自己身上。我就想，这奇怪得就像喝得烂醉去参加葬礼，你知道吗？就像，稍微尊重一下。首先，这是一场中午的比赛。你怎么能喝得那么醉，你知道吗？但是——
You know how you get that drunk. You start at 7:30.
你知道你怎么喝得那么醉的。你从7点半就开始了。
I know, I know. I've done that before, so I shouldn't say anything.
我知道，我知道。我以前也那样做过，所以我没资格说什么。
Honestly, seeing drunk kids stumbling back from the game on Saturday, that was the one thing that made me feel like the town was going back to normal, for better or for worse.
说实话，周六看到喝醉的孩子们从比赛现场跌跌撞撞地走回来，那是一件事，让我觉得这个城镇正在恢复正常，不管是好是坏。
Sarah Koenig. Coming up, we go back in time, through the miracle of audio recording technology, before all this happened, before all the trouble, to the program that we did back in 2009 about Penn State. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
莎拉·柯尼格。接下来，通过音频录制技术的奇迹，我们将回到过去，在那一切发生之前，在所有麻烦之前，回到我们在2009年关于宾夕法尼亚州立大学制作的节目。稍后继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司，我们的节目继续。
This podcast of This American Life is brought you by audible.com, which is a provider of audio books with more than 100,000 downloadable titles across all types of literature, including fiction, nonfiction, and periodicals. For listeners of the This American Life podcast, Audible is offering a free audio book of your choice when you try audible free for 14 days. A title they suggest that This American Life listeners might enjoy is Steve Jobs by Walter Isaacson, the new book based on hundreds of interviews with Steve Jobs and the people around him. To try Audible today with the free audio book of your choice, go to audible.com/American. All the details are on their website. That's audible.com/American.
本期《This American Life》播客由audible.com赞助，它是音频书籍提供商，拥有超过10万种可下载的图书，涵盖所有类型的文学作品，包括小说、非小说和期刊。《This American Life》播客的听众在尝试Audible 14天免费服务时，Audible提供一本你选择的免费有声读物。他们建议《This American Life》听众可能会喜欢的一本书是沃尔特·艾萨克森（Walter Isaacson）的《史蒂夫·乔布斯传》，这是一本基于对史蒂夫·乔布斯及他身边人数百次采访而成的新书。如需试用Audible并获得一本免费有声读物，请访问audible.com/American。所有详细信息都在他们的网站上。即audible.com/American。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. This week on our show we've been talking about Penn State and how people there are reacting to grand jury charges that a former assistant coach sexually abused young boys. The charge is that Penn State officials failed to report the abuse to authorities. In this half of the show, we're going to play excerpts from our 2009 episode about Penn State. That show is about mostly the fact that the school was named the nation's number one party school that year, so it's mostly about partying and drinking, which have nothing at all to do with this sex abuse scandal. Just need to get out in front of that right now.
这里是《This American Life》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。本周在我们的节目中，我们一直在讨论宾夕法尼亚州立大学，以及人们对大陪审团指控一名以前的助理教练性虐待年轻男孩的反应。指控称，宾夕法尼亚州立大学的官员未向当局报告这些虐待行为。在本节节目中，我们将播放我们在2009年关于宾夕法尼亚州立大学的那期节目片段。那期节目主要是关于这所学校在那一年被评为全国第一派对学校的事实，所以主要是关于聚会和喝酒，这与这起性虐待丑闻完全无关。我需要立即把这一点说明白。
But that said, you can't talk about partying and drinking at Penn State without talking about football. Football is a kind of a location where a lot of things like that occur. And though these stories are about drinking, throughout all the stories, there are these moments where you see just how central it is in the life of Penn State. You see the before in the before and after of this scandal.
但话虽如此，如果不谈橄榄球，你就无法谈论宾夕法尼亚州立大学的派对和饮酒。橄榄球是很多类似事情发生的场所。虽然这些故事是关于饮酒的，但在所有故事中，都有一些时刻让你看到它在宾夕法尼亚州立大学的生活中是多么核心。你看到了这场丑闻的前后。
And in the before-- and this explains a lot about the after-- people love Penn State, and the love was uncomplicated. Students were spontaneously telling all of us how much they loved the school, how they never wanted the college experience to end. They chanted the school chant, "We Are Penn State," not just in the football stadium. It was in the student union, it was in the shuttle bus. They would just chant it, out of the blue.
而在之前——这解释了之后的很多事情——人们热爱宾夕法尼亚州立大学，这种爱是单纯的。学生们自发地告诉我们他们有多热爱这所学校，他们有多么不希望大学生活结束。他们高呼校歌“我们是宾夕法尼亚州立大学”，不仅在橄榄球场。在学生会，在穿梭巴士上，他们都会随口高呼。
["WE ARE PENN STATE" CHANT]
[高呼“我们是宾夕法尼亚州立大学”]
They said "We are Penn State" in conversation, to make a point. They were part of this club that they were really excited to be part of.
他们在交谈中也会说“我们是宾夕法尼亚州立大学”，以强调观点。他们是这个俱乐部的一部分，他们为此感到非常兴奋。
In 2009, we were there for the last home game of the season, exactly two years and one week ago. Penn State was 44,000 students at the time. To describe the level of drinking and partying and football fandom, at one point in the show, I was joined in the studio, back in 2009, by Sarah Koenig, who you heard earlier in today's show.
2009年，我们在赛季的最后一场主场比赛时在那里，就在两年前的一周前。宾夕法尼亚州立大学当时有4.4万名学生。为了描述饮酒、派对和橄榄球粉丝的热度，在节目中的某个时刻，2009年时，我曾与今天节目中出现的莎拉·柯尼格一起在录音室里。
You're right. A couple of weeks before you guys came to State College, there was this huge freak snowstorm, and they had to cancel tailgating for the first time anyone could remember because the conditions were so dangerous by the field. But it didn't stop anyone. I saw people tailgating in their yards, on their front lawns-- even in my neighborhood, I went into a parking garage and found all these people on the fourth floor, which was really strange to see. I mean, it's a parking garage, so there's dirty cars everywhere, the ceiling is low, it's cold, it's dark.
你是对的。在你们去州立学院的前几周，发生了一场巨大的怪异暴风雪，他们不得不取消了有史以来第一次尾门派对（tailgating），因为场地条件太危险了。但它并没有阻止任何人。我看到人们在他们的院子里、在前草坪上尾门聚会——甚至在我住的社区，我走进了一个停车场，发现四楼全是这些人，这真的很奇怪。我的意思是，这是一个停车场，所以到处都是脏兮兮的车，天花板很低，又冷又暗。
At the end of one row of cars, there were these two tables pushed together in an L-shape with tablecloths and all kinds of food and a couple birthday cakes.
在车行尽头，有两张桌子拼在一起呈L形，铺着桌布，摆满了各种食物和几个生日蛋糕。
Whose birthday is this?
这是谁的生日？
It's my birthday, it's my birthday, my 21st birthday.
是我的生日，是我的生日，我21岁的生日。
Happy birthday.
生日快乐。
Thank you.
谢谢。
And what are you doing on the fourth floor of a parking garage?
那你为什么在停车场的四楼？
I'm getting drunk and tailgating.
我正在喝得烂醉，进行尾门聚会。
Describe your headgear there.
描述一下你的头饰。
It's a crown with a 21 that's on fire, and it says, "Where's the bar?"
这是一个写着“酒吧在哪？”的皇冠，上面还有一个着火的21数字。
So who brought all this food?
那这些食物是谁带来的？
My mom and dad. Because they love me, and they're the best.
我的爸爸妈妈。因为他们爱我，他们是最好的。
About a half dozen older people were there, too, her parents and some of their friends. And there were a bunch of other tailgates happening around us, and one couple was having their 40th wedding anniversary.
大约有半打老年人也在那里，她的父母和他们的一些朋友。我们周围还有一堆其他的尾门聚会，有一对夫妇正在庆祝结婚40周年。
Wow. In the garage?
哇。在停车场？
In the garage, yeah. At one point, a woman probably in her 50s walked up and handed the birthday girl a red plastic cup.
在停车场，是的。有一次，一位大概50多岁的女士走过来，递给寿星一个红色塑料杯。
Aw, thank you! What is this?
啊，谢谢！这是什么？
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
Is there alcohol in it?
里面有酒精吗？
Most definitely.
那是肯定的。
Oh my god, this is the strongest drink I've ever had in my life! They just brought me a really strong alcoholic lemonade.
天哪，这是我这辈子喝过最浓的饮料！他们刚刚给了我一杯酒精浓度很高的柠檬水。
Is that your daughter? Are you the mom?
那是你女儿吗？你是妈妈吗？
No, no. We're parked over there.
不，不。我们停在那边。
You just saw that this is happening.
你只是看到这里在发生这些事。
Yes.
是的。
We've got to keep ourselves entertained somehow, right?
我们必须得找点乐子来消遣一下，对吧？
Watch the 21-year-old get plastered, that's the entertainment?
看着那个21岁的女孩喝得酩酊大醉，这就是娱乐活动？
Exactly, exactly.
正是，正是。
Thank you so much for the drink!
太感谢你的饮料了！
At tailgate parties you see just how deeply embedded drinking is in life at Penn State.  It's entire families. It's several generations together. It's outdoor public drinking, which gives you this feeling when you're there that the whole world is drinking. Probably because there's so much of it.
在尾门派对上，你可以看到饮酒在宾夕法尼亚州立大学的生活中是多么根深蒂固。这是整个家庭。这是几代人在一起。这是露天的公共饮酒，这让你在那里有一种全世界都在喝酒的感觉。可能是因为酒实在太多了。
In 2009, when we were there, Penn State had largest stadium in North America. Holds over 100,000 people. So the tailgates are these huge masses of humanity spread out as far as you can see, all around the stadium, starting at 8 in the morning, starting really early, which is when these alums got here. They talked to one of the producers, Aaron Scott.
2009年我们在那里时，宾夕法尼亚州立大学拥有北美最大的体育场。能容纳超过10万人。所以尾门聚会是巨大的人群，绵延到你所能看到的尽头，在体育场周围，早上8点就开始了，开始得很早，这些校友就是那时候到的。他们和制片人之一亚伦·斯科特（Aaron Scott）谈过。
So you went to bed, three or four. You got up, and you're drinking again.
所以你睡了三四个小时。你起床了，又开始喝了。
Yes.
是的。
Is it ever too early to drink?
喝酒会嫌太早吗？
No, never.
不，从来不会。
Eight in the morning means, by the way, that if it's a night game, they will tailgate for 12 hours, in the cold, in the freezing cold sometimes, before kickoff.
顺便说一句，早上八点意味着如果是夜间比赛，他们会在寒冷中，有时是在冰冷的严寒中，在开球前进行12小时的尾门聚会。
I talked to a bunch of alums at a tailgate about what would happen if they weren't allowed to drink it all.
我和一群校友谈论过如果他们不允许喝酒会发生什么。
I think there would be a revolt. I think there would be a huge, huge pushback from the alumni that donate a lot of money to school to say that you can't have alcohol to tailgate.
我想会发生暴动。我想那些为学校捐赠大量金钱的校友会进行巨大的阻力，声称不允许在尾门聚会时喝酒。
That's Mark Johnson, class of 1977.
那是马克·约翰逊（Mark Johnson），1977届学生。
It's just part of the culture. I mean, that's why this school sells 110,000 tickets for every-- just, it's a part of it. It's just part of that tradition.
这只是文化的一部分。我的意思是，这就是为什么这所学校每场比赛都能卖出11万张票……这只是其中的一部分。这只是传统的一部分。
Usually pounding down drinks at eight in the morning can be kind of sad. But the main thing about this kind of drinking, where it's tied in with tradition, and football, and family, and overwhelming sense of school spirit, is that it feels incredibly wholesome. The whole campus feels like a Chevy commercial. It's welcoming people.  It's friendly. It's hard to resist.
通常在早上八点就开始酗酒可能看起来有点悲伤。但这种与传统、橄榄球、家庭和强烈的学校精神联系在一起的饮酒的主要特征是，它感觉非常健康。整个校园感觉就像雪佛兰的广告。它是受欢迎的。它是友好的。很难抗拒。
You could go to any tailgate here, any Penn State tailgate, and you are just welcome.
你可以去这里的任何一个尾门聚会，任何一个宾夕法尼亚州立大学的尾门聚会，你都会受到欢迎。
Here's a junior named Megan Klock.
这是大三学生梅根·克洛克（Megan Klock）。
I mean, you could go up to someone that's cooking at a grill, and be like, hey, can I have a burger? And they're like, oh, sure. So it's like endless food. Everyone's friendly with everyone. Just the atmosphere here is-- I have never experienced anything like Penn State atmosphere.
我的意思是，你可以走到一个在烤架上做饭的人身边，说，嘿，我能来个汉堡吗？他们会说，哦，当然。所以就像有无穷无尽的食物。每个人都对彼此很友好。这里的氛围就是……我从未体验过像宾夕法尼亚州立大学这样的氛围。
Sarah met this next guy, Peter, drinking outside the stadium with his friends before the game. He's from Slovakia.
莎拉在比赛前遇见了下一个人，彼得，在体育场外和朋友喝酒。他来自斯洛伐克。
I came to US, and I started watching baseball and football, and I didn't understand at all the rules. It was just a big blah to me. And I didn't get my football tickets my freshman year, but I was able to go in one or two games. And I guess I started to like the atmosphere that is surrounded by the football. And it kind of reminded me of home, where everyone is welcoming, everyone's a big family, and no matter where you're from, you root for the same team. It made me feel like I'm home again and surrounded by friends. And so I just love it now. I heart [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. I'm getting emotional.
我来到美国，开始看棒球和橄榄球，我一点也没弄懂规则。对我来说那简直是一团糟。我大一时没买到橄榄球门票，但我能进去看一两场比赛。我想我开始喜欢橄榄球周围的那种氛围了。它让我想起了家乡，每个人都很受欢迎，每个人都是一个大家庭，无论你来自哪里，你都支持同一支球队。它让我感觉像是又回到了家，周围都是朋友。所以我现在就是爱它。我爱[听不清]。我都感动了。
This sense-- that we're a family, we're about football, everybody in the school is one-- it spills over from the football games into the whole weekend. It's a week, actually.
这种感觉——我们是一个家庭，我们是橄榄球，学校里的每个人都是一体的——它从橄榄球比赛溢出到整个周末。其实是一个星期。
It's Friday night, the night before the football game, outside East Hall, one of the big freshmen dorms. And dozens of kids are lined up to the free shuttle buses that are going to take them across campus to the frats and parties on the other side. Two of our producers, Jane Feltes and Lisa Pollak, noticed that all the girls wore these ratty-looking hoodies and jackets over their dress-up clothes. Somebody told them that word for this is "frackets." They went up to some girls to confirm that.
这是周五晚上，橄榄球比赛的前一晚，在东大厅外，这是大型大一宿舍楼之一。几十个孩子排队等候免费的穿梭巴士，这些巴士将带他们穿过校园去另一边的兄弟会和派对现场。我们的两位制片人简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）和丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）注意到所有的女孩在她们精心打扮的衣服外面都穿着这些看起来破烂不堪的连帽衫和夹克。有人告诉她们这个词叫“frackets”。她们走到一些女孩身边确认了一下。
Have you guys heard of something called frackets?
你们听说过叫“frackets”的东西吗？
Oh yeah, that's what we're wearing.
哦，是的，这就是我们穿的东西。
Oh, we have a pro in frackets.
哦，我们有穿frackets的专家。
A fracket, by definition, is a jacket made for frats. It's basically a crappy jacket that's cheap and you don't care about.
Fracket，按照定义，是专为兄弟会聚会（frat）做的夹克。它基本上是一件便宜、破旧的夹克，你并不在意它。
Yeah. Because they get lost. They get, like, puked on. You don't want that back.
是的。因为它会丢。它会被，比如，吐在上面。你可不想要回它。
You don't want it back. Just lose it, yeah.
你不想要回它。就是丢掉它，是的。
Jane rode on the bus with the freshmen. She joins me now.
简坐着大一新生坐的巴士。她现在加入了我的谈话。
So that girl, her name's Chuy, she's from Saudi Arabia. When I met her and her friend Megna, they were already on their second loop around campus. They were kind of drunk and they'd missed their stop the first time. And on this bus, everyone keeps breaking into song.
那个女孩，她叫楚伊（Chuy），她来自沙特阿拉伯。当我见到她和她的朋友梅格娜（Megna）时，她们已经在校园里兜第二圈了。她们有点醉了，第一次还坐过站了。在这辆巴士上，每个人都在唱歌。
[STUDENTS SINGING]
[学生唱歌]
What is happening?
发生什么事了？
This is the drunk bus. Good timing.
这是醉鬼巴士。时机正好。
Oh my god. Is this the same stop where we found out that we were late?
噢，天哪。这是我们发现我们迟到的那一站吗？
Penn State's administration does a pretty thorough job surveying students to track how much they're drinking. Surveys show that every Friday and every Saturday night, 75% of the school drinks. That's over 30,000 people, an average of four and half drinks per person. And the students drink those drinks in about three hours, average. To put those numbers in perspective, binge drinking, or as it's been rebranded lately, high-risk or dangerous drinking, is defined as four drinks for a woman or five drinks for a man consumed in just two hours.
宾夕法尼亚州立大学的行政部门在调查学生饮酒量方面做得相当彻底。调查显示，每个周五和周六晚上，75%的学生都在喝酒。那超过3万人，平均每人喝四杯半。而学生们在三小时内平均喝完这些酒。为了客观地看待这些数字，酗酒，或者像最近被重塑为高风险或危险饮酒，被定义为女性喝四杯，男性喝五杯，仅在两小时内喝完。
[STUDENTS SINGING]
[学生唱歌]
And to get down into the details of Penn State's numbers, it works out to over half the students regularly binge drinking, which is just a little bit above the national average for college students.
为了深入了解宾夕法尼亚州立大学的数字，超过一半的学生有规律地酗酒，这比大学生全国平均水平略高一点。
[STUDENTS SINGING]
[学生唱歌]
Lots of students said something that was hard to argue with. When else are also they going to get a chance to do this? Like I was talking to a senior--
很多学生说了些很难反驳的话。他们还有什么时候有机会做这种事？就像我和一位大四学生谈话时——
So what's the wildest thing you've seen at a party at this school?
那么你在学校的派对上见过的最狂野的事情是什么？
Wildest thing at a party? Somebody streaking completely naked, and pretending to throw monkey feces as they were doing it. And that was me.
派对上最狂野的事？有人一丝不挂地裸奔，并在做的时候假装扔猴子粪便。那个人就是我。
That was you?
那是你？
That was me.
那就是我。
When was that?
那是什么时候？
Last week. I mean, you can only do that stuff now, when you're in college, you know? You can't do it-- I wouldn't be able to do it six months from now. It's college.
上周。我的意思是，你只有在现在，当你上大学的时候，才能做这些事情，你知道吗？你不能在……六个月后我就做不到了。这是大学。
Yes, there's a downside to all this. In the surveys of students done by the school, a fourth of Penn State students say that drinking has caused them to miss class or get behind on the schoolwork. 15% say that they've been pushed, hit, or assaulted. 7% say that drinking led to what the survey called-- this is their euphemism-- quote, "an unwanted sexual experience." There actually isn't data at Penn State linking drinking and date rape. 6% said that they'd gotten into what you would call a real physical fight. And then there are crimes that you never hear of unless you live in a place like State College.
是的，所有这一切都有负面影响。在学校对学生进行的调查中，四分之一的宾夕法尼亚州立大学学生说饮酒导致他们旷课或学习落后。15%的人说他们被推挤、殴打或侵犯过。7%的人说饮酒导致了他们所谓的——这是他们的委婉说法——引述“不想要的性体验”。宾夕法尼亚州立大学实际上并没有数据将饮酒与约会强奸联系起来。6%的人说他们卷入过所谓的真正的身体斗争。还有一些除非你住像州立学院这样的地方，否则你永远听不到的犯罪。
Our daughter came into the kitchen while we were in the midst of hurriedly getting everything done, and said something to the effect of, mommy, I want to play my room. Can you please get that man out of my bed? And I remember having said something to the effect-- there's no man in your bed. And she actually went away, and came back a few minutes later, so I guess she went up to check. And she comes down--there is a man in my bed, and I want to play in my room. Would you please get him out of there?
当我们匆忙完成所有事情时，我们的女儿走进厨房，说了类似这样的话，妈妈，我想玩我的房间。你能把那个男人从我的床上弄走吗？我记得我说了类似——你的床上没有男人。她真的走开了，几分钟后又回来了，所以我想她去检查了。她下来说——我的床上有个男人，我想玩我的房间。你能把他弄走吗？
This is a long-time State College resident named Nina White, and the man on the bed, of course, was a college student who committed a surprisingly common crime in this town. He came to her house drunk, found a comfortable place, and fell asleep.
这是一位在州立学院住了很久的居民，名叫妮娜·怀特（Nina White），当然，床上的男人是一个在镇上犯了令人惊讶的常见罪行的大学生。他喝醉了来到她家，找了一个舒服的地方，然后睡着了。
When we were at Penn State in 2009, it was the neighbors who had the biggest concerns about all the drinking because of incidents like this. And there was one of the neighbors in particular who got us interested in in all the partying as something to report on.  That neighbor was our colleague, This American Life producer Sarah Koenig, who, as I said, lives in State College. Lives there because her husband teaches at the school. And the episode that we did in 2009 began with us sitting on the porch.
2009年我们在宾夕法尼亚州立大学时，正是邻居们最关心所有这些酗酒问题，因为发生了诸如此类的事件。并且有一位邻居特别让我们对所有的派对作为报道对象产生了兴趣。那位邻居是我们的同事，《This American Life》制片人莎拉·柯尼格，正如我所说，她住在州立学院。住在那里是因为她丈夫在学校教书。我们在2009年制作的那期节目以我们在门廊上坐着开始。
One, two, three. OK, Sarah, so it's ten of one on a Friday night in November, and we're sitting on your porch. And it seems pretty quiet.
一、二、三。好了，莎拉，现在是11月一个周五晚上的凌晨12点50分，我们正坐在你的门廊上。看起来相当安静。
It's not that bad.
没那么糟。
By day, I have to say, Sarah's neighborhood is like a college town that you would see in an old Hollywood film. It's beautiful professors' homes, built in the '20s and '30s, it's tree-lined streets, it's gardens. But by night, we'd been on that porch for five minutes when--
白天，我不得不说，莎拉的社区就像你在旧好莱坞电影中看到的那种大学城。它是美丽的教授住宅，建于20世纪20和30年代，它是绿树成荫的街道，它是花园。但到了晚上，我们在那个门廊待了五分钟时——
They seem drunk. These kids seem drunk. This couple here, they're sort of staggering a bit. I think he's like holding her up or something.
他们看起来喝醉了。这些孩子看起来喝醉了。这对夫妇在这里，他们有点摇摇晃晃。我想他像是扶着她之类的。
It's nine students walking down the middle of the street. Happens all the time.
那是九个学生走在街中间。经常发生。
It's noisy, right? It's like it doesn't occur to them at all, I think, that there are people in these houses trying to sleep. And I kind of remember being that way in college, too, actually.
很吵，对吧？就像他们完全没意识到，我想，这些房子里有人在试图睡觉。而且我有点记得在大学里自己也是那样，其实。
Yeah, I do too.
是的，我也记得。
Six minutes later, there's another group of drunk students. One tosses something onto a lawn.
六分钟后，又是另一群喝醉的学生。其中一个往草坪上扔了什么东西。
Can you guys pick up your trash, please?  Can you pick up your plate, your pizza plate? Please? People leave here. They pay no attention.
你们能把垃圾捡起来吗，拜托？你们能捡起你们的盘子，你们的披萨盘吗？拜托？人们住在这里。他们根本不注意。
Five minutes after that, we hear this clattering from the alley that runs next to Sarah's house.
五分钟后，我们听到从莎拉房子旁的小巷传来的撞击声。
Whoa, what was that? Actually, I'd kind of like to know what that was. What's going on?
哇，那是什么？其实，我倒是挺想知道那是什么。发生什么事了？
We run down the alley, and two college boys run away as they see us coming. "Don't go back there, you could get raped," they yell to Sarah.
我们跑进小巷，两个大学生看到我们过来就跑了。“别回那儿，你可能会被强奸，”他们对莎拉喊道。
See? OK. They just threw somebody's trash can, or like dropkicked it up in the air.
看到了吧？好的。他们只是扔了某人的垃圾桶，或者像是把它踢到半空中。
12 minutes after that, from the other direction, we hear a scraping, and a loud rumbling, I guess.
在那之后的12分钟，从另一个方向，我们听到了一阵刮擦声，还有一阵巨大的轰鸣声，我想。
That's somebody's property. That might have been a sign, actually.
那是某人的财产。那可能是一个标志，其实。
I don't know how many street signs you need to hear dragged through your neighborhood before you could recognize the sound it makes from all the way around the corner. But apparently my colleague Sarah has seen whatever that number is. We go to investigate and find two guys.
我不知道在你能识别出从角落转弯处发出的声音之前，你需要听到多少个路牌被拖过你的社区。但显然我的同事莎拉见过那个次数。我们去调查并发现了两个人。
So just describe what you've got here.
所以描述一下你们这里有什么。
A stop sign. Nice big pole on it.
一个停车标志。上面有个漂亮的杆子。
A stop sign. That's kind of a big thing when you see it up close, isn't it?
一个停车标志。当你近距离观察它时，那是个大东西，不是吗？
Sorry.
抱歉。
Where did you find this? Like, where does it belong?
你们在哪里找到这个的？比如，它属于哪里？
I don't know.
我不知道。
That is a good question.
这是个好问题。
We just found it on a lawn. We found it on a lawn.
我们只是在草坪上发现了它。我们在草坪上发现了它。
It was already ripped up.
它已经被拔出来了。
Yeah, it was already [BLEEP] on someone's lawn.
是的，它已经在某人的草坪上[被搞砸了]。
We just decided, hey, why not make use of and take it?
我们只是决定，嘿，为什么不利用它并带走呢？
Of course, this story makes no sense at all. I inform the two guys that I don't need to know their names.
当然，这个故事根本没有任何意义。我告诉那两个人我不需要知道他们的名字。
Well, in that case, we took it from the corner right there.
好吧，如果是那样的话，我们是从那边的拐角处拿走的。
Which one?
哪一个？
Where that car just turned.
那辆车刚转过去的地方。
Pulled it out of the ground?
从地里拔出来的？
Yeah, it was cemented in pretty well. Just get a little rocking back and forth between two people, comes right out.
是的，它用水泥固定得相当好。只要两个人稍微来回摇晃一下，就出来了。
Did you guys come from like a house party somewhere?
你们是从什么家庭聚会过来的吗？
Ah, no.  We were just hanging out with a bunch of friends, just drinking. Taking some shots.
啊，不。我们只是和一群朋友待在一起，只是在喝酒。喝点酒。
Seems like kind of an academic distinction to me, but.
对我来说这似乎是一个学术上的区别，但是。
With that, the other guy starts running with the street sign toward Garner Street, which is hard because it's attached to a seven-foot metal pole, and it's heavy. Sarah and I go back around the corner to her front yard. The evening is not over at all. Just in time to spot another student, this one coming out of her garden, Sarah assumes, from the bushes back there.
随之，另一个人开始带着路牌向加纳街（Garner Street）跑去，这很困难，因为它连接着一根七英尺高的金属杆，而且很重。莎拉和我转过街角回到她的前院。夜晚根本还没结束。刚好赶上看到另一个学生，这个学生从她的花园里出来，莎拉推测，从后面的灌木丛里。
I didn't pee.
我没撒尿。
Really?
真的吗？
I never pee.
我从来不撒尿。
Really?
真的吗？
I was just sitting down.
我只是坐下来。
He goes, and it's not a minute later that Sarah points towards the alley where there are three girls in miniskirts, under streetlights, fully visible.
他走了，没过一分钟莎拉就指向小巷，那里有三个穿着超短裙的女孩，在路灯下，完全可见。
Peeing, peeing, peeing, peeing, peeing.
撒尿，撒尿，撒尿，撒尿，撒尿。
One girl hikes up her skirt.
一个女孩提起她的裙子。
Wait, step back, step back, step back.
等等，退后，退后，退后。
OK. But they're peeing in my yard. They're peeing in my yard. That's my car, OK, and three feet back is a girl's white ass, peeing.
好的。但她们在我的院子里撒尿。她们在我的院子里撒尿。那是我的车，好的，三英尺后面是一个女孩的白屁股，撒尿。
She saw we saw her. She stopped. You know, that might be why the plants grow really, really well in that spot. I'm just realizing.
她看到我们看到她了。她停下了。你知道，那可能就是为什么植物在那个点长得特别特别好的原因。我刚刚意识到。
Sarah's caught other groups of girls peeing in that same spot. Once she heard a girl say, "This is a good place. I go here all the time."
莎拉抓到过其他几群女孩在同一个地方撒尿。有一次她听到一个女孩说，“这是一个好地方。我一直来这里。”
They're so embarrassed. There's like muffled giggling happening across the street.
她们太尴尬了。马路对面传来了闷声的咯咯笑声。
The weekend that we recorded this, back in 2009, Penn State was in fact the country's number one party school, named by people who name the number one party school in our country, the Princeton Review. And this is apparently what it means to be the number one party school in the country. From the moment that Sarah and I turned on the tape recorder to the moment that she sent those girls looking for somebody else's yard to pee in-- total time, 34 minutes. It's 1:30 in the morning now.
我们录制这个周末时，2009年时，宾夕法尼亚州立大学确实是全国第一派对学校，由命名我们国家第一派对学校的人们评选，即普林斯顿评论（Princeton Review）。这就是成为全国第一派对学校意味着什么。从莎拉和我打开录音机的那一刻起，到她送那些女孩寻找别人院子去撒尿的那一刻——总时间，34分钟。现在是凌晨1点半。
The fact that we saw that much mayhem sort of going on at one corner-- so that means it's, multiply that by this entire neighborhood and other neighborhoods around. People are peeing everywhere, garbage cans are getting kicked, stop signs are getting pulled out of the road, people are littering-- you know.
我们在一个街角看到那么多混乱在发生——所以这意味着，乘以整个社区和其他周围的社区。人们到处在撒尿，垃圾桶被踢，停车标志被拔出道路，人们在乱扔垃圾——你知道的。
The Princeton Review chooses the number one party school from online student surveys. 120,000 students at 371 schools around the country answered these questions. How widely used are beer, alcohol, marijuana, and other drugs or your school? How big is frat life at your school? And finally, how many hours do you study each day? The students aren't randomly selected, so it's not, strictly speaking, a scientific survey. But every year, Penn State ranks very high. In the last five years, it's been the number three party school twice. It's been the number seven party school in the country, it's been the number nine party school in the country, and of course, number one party school in 2009 the year we were there.
普林斯顿评论从在线学生调查中选择第一派对学校。全国371所学校的12万名学生回答了这些问题。你们学校啤酒、酒精、大麻和其他药物使用有多广泛？你们学校兄弟会生活有多庞大？最后，你们每天学习几个小时？学生们不是随机抽样的，所以严格来说，这不是科学调查。但每年，宾夕法尼亚州立大学排名都很高。过去五年里，它两次成为第三派对学校。它曾是全国第七派对学校，曾是全国第九派对学校，当然，2009年我们在那里时是第一派对学校。
That year, a freshman named Joe Dado died in an alcohol-related incident in September, just a month into the school year. He was 18. In the episode that we did back then, Sarah Koenig did a big story about the university's response to this incident and to the level of alcohol consumption at the school in general. When these kinds of deaths have happened at other schools-- Colorado State, MIT, Indiana University, UVA-- administrations have used the deaths to push for change. Not at Penn State. Nobody used the occasion to urge the students to stop drinking so much. Instead, the message from the administration was, if you're going to get plastered, do it more responsibly.
那一年，一个叫乔·达多（Joe Dado）的新生在九月，即学年开始仅一个月后，死于一起与酒精有关的事件。他18岁。在那期节目中，莎拉·柯尼格做了一个关于学校对这一事件以及学校总体酒精消耗水平的反应的大型报道。当这种死亡在其他学校发生时——科罗拉多州立大学、麻省理工学院、印第安纳大学、弗吉尼亚大学——行政部门利用死亡来推动改变。在宾夕法尼亚州立大学没有。没有人利用这个机会敦促学生停止酗酒。相反，行政部门的信息是，如果你要喝得酩酊大醉，请更负责任地做。
As we noted at the time, maybe the administration figured that this message had a better chance of sticking. And it did stick. The lesson students took-- we heard this from students that we talked to-- was not the Dado drank too much, but that he would have been alive if only he hadn't gone off by himself.
正如我们当时所指出的，也许行政部门认为这个信息更有可能被采纳。确实采纳了。学生们学到的教训——我们从谈话的学生那里听到的——不是达多喝得太多，而是如果他没有独自走开，他本来会活下来。
Sarah talked in the show about how the University's president, Graham Spanier, came in 15 years before that as a crusader against binge drinking who was not shy about calling alcohol use the school's biggest problem, and he got pushback for that. From alumni, from university trustees. He was booed by students at a football game. And he stopped hammering the topic so publicly.
莎拉在节目中谈到了大学校长格雷厄姆·斯帕尼尔是如何在15年前作为一个反对酗酒的斗士进来的，他不害羞于称酒精使用是学校最大的问题，他为此受到了反击。来自校友，来自大学受托人。他在橄榄球比赛中被学生们嘘声。他停止如此公开地抨击这个话题。
Here's from that story that Sarah did back in 2009. You hear, she actually goes to Spanier.  And here's Spanier in this clip. He was fired last week after the child sex abuse scandal broke.
这是莎拉在2009年做的那个故事里的片段。你听到她实际上去找了斯帕尼尔。这是片段中的斯帕尼尔。他上周在性虐待丑闻爆发后被解雇了。
What you hear all the time around here, off the record, from local residents, from faculty, from other administrators, is that Spanier really can't or won't do anything more draconian about the drinking problem here-- make fraternities dry, say, or curb tailgating-- because politically, he simply cannot risk alienating those sacred cows Simms is talking about. Especially alumni and athletics, meaning football, which brings in enormous money.
你在这里一直听到的，非正式的，来自当地居民，来自教职员工，来自其他行政人员，是斯帕尼尔真的不能或不愿对这里的酗酒问题采取更严厉的行动——比如让兄弟会禁酒，或者限制尾门聚会——因为从政治上讲，他根本无法冒险疏远Simms所说的那些神圣母牛。尤其是校友和体育项目，意味着橄榄球，它带来了巨大的金钱。
Tens of thousands of alumni come to football games, rent skyboxes. The only places in the stadium where you can drink, by the way. They arrange their lives around the season. It's a big part of why they give money to the school. Last year, alums and other donors give $182 million.
成千上万的校友来橄榄球比赛，租用豪华包厢。顺便说一句，这是体育场里唯一可以喝酒的地方。他们围绕着赛季安排他们的生活。这是他们向学校捐钱的重要原因。去年，校友和其他捐赠者捐赠了1.82亿美元。
I asked Spanier if there was something he needed to be careful about here, in terms of the connection between football and donors and booze.
我问斯帕尼尔，在橄榄球与捐赠者和酒的关系方面，他是否需要小心。
No. I don't buy that at all. That's just speculation that you hear from people, like, oh, that must be part of the issue. They would never go after the alumni. The fact is, what happens with six or seven home games is not the heart of this issue here. We're talking about the weekend in, weekend out, every day of the week throughout the year kind of issue.
不。我完全不买账。那只是你从人们那里听到的猜测，比如，哦，那一定是问题的一部分。他们永远不会对付校友。事实是，六七场主场比赛发生的事情不是这里问题的核心。我们谈论的是周末、周末，一年中每天那种问题。
When this comes up, it's sort of like, someone will say, well, why don't they just make tailgating dry? No alcohol on University property? Is that kind of thing ever even brought up as like a, we just want to signal a culture change, we're just going to make a big bold move and say, we're going to become a different kind of school now. Is that ever, like, on the table?
当这种情况出现时，有点像，有人会说，嗯，为什么他们不直接让尾门聚会禁酒？大学财产上没有酒精？那种事情有没有被作为一种，我们只是想发出文化改变的信号，我们只是要做出一个重大的勇敢举措，说，我们要成为一种不同的学校了。这种情况是否在桌面上讨论过？
No, I don't think so. I can't envision telling alumni of legal age that they can't drink on a football weekend, and seeing that that's going to change the problem of alcohol consumption among underage students on college campuses. I don't think those two things are really tied together.
不，我不这么认为。我无法想象告诉达到法定年龄的校友他们不能在橄榄球周末喝酒，并看到那会改变大学生酗酒的问题。我不认为这两件事真的联系在一起。
How far would administrators go to protect the football program? Of course, that's at the heart of the current scandal. And with football so central to Penn State's fundraising, it's easy to see why they would protect it.
行政部门会走多远来保护橄榄球项目？当然，这是当前丑闻的核心。由于橄榄球对宾夕法尼亚州立大学的筹款如此核心，很容易理解为什么他们会保护它。
A Penn State professor named Michael Berube wrote an op-ed in the New York Times this week about how football built Penn State into the school it is today. He talks about how dramatically the school has improved since Coach Joe Paterno first arrived decades ago, how Paterno endowed the professorship he holds, and lists the academic departments at Penn State-- English, Sociology, Anthropology-- that are now rated among the top ten university programs by the National Research Council. He notes that after Joe Paterno's first national championship, Paterno declared that the school had to improve its library, because quote, "You can't have a great university without a great library." Paterno and his wife led the capital campaign. The new library building is named for them.
一位宾夕法尼亚州立大学教授名叫迈克尔·贝鲁贝（Michael Berube），本周在《纽约时报》发表了一篇评论文章，讲述了橄榄球是如何将宾夕法尼亚州立大学建设成今天的学校的。他谈到自从几十年前乔·帕特诺教练第一次到来以来，学校是如何戏剧性地改善的，帕特诺如何资助了他所持有的教授席位，并列出了宾夕法尼亚州立大学的学术部门——英语、社会学、人类学——现在被国家研究委员会评为前十名大学项目。他指出，在乔·帕特诺第一次全国冠军赛后，帕特诺宣称学校必须改善其图书馆，因为引述：“没有伟大的图书馆，你就不能拥有伟大的大学。”帕特诺和他的妻子领导了资本运动。新的图书馆大楼以他们的名字命名。
When Penn State football has a winning season, enrollment goes up. Somebody who's tried to quantify just what football means to Penn State financially is Philadelphia Inquirer reporter Frank Fitzpatrick, whose 2000 series on the business of football at Penn State was nominated for a Pulitzer Prize. I reached him in State College this week, where he was writing a story about the current scandal.
当宾夕法尼亚州立大学橄榄球队有一个获胜赛季时，入学人数就会上升。一位试图量化橄榄球对宾夕法尼亚州立大学财务意义的人是《费城问询报》（Philadelphia Inquirer）记者弗兰克·菲茨帕特里克（Frank Fitzpatrick），他2000年关于宾夕法尼亚州立大学橄榄球商业的系列报道被提名普利策奖。本周我在州立学院联系了他，他当时正在写关于当前丑闻的故事。
You know, without football it's hard to imagine what this place would look like. Football has really been the engine driving the growth here.
你知道，没有橄榄球，很难想象这个地方会是什么样子。橄榄球确实一直是推动这里发展的引擎。
How much money does Penn State football bring in?
宾夕法尼亚州立大学橄榄球带来了多少钱？
Well, I believe in 2010, they brought in, I think it was $72 million. They had costs of, I believe, $19 million. So that's a profit of $53 million, which is a profit margin that most Fortune 500 companies would be envious of.
好吧，我相信在2010年，他们带来了，我想是7200万美元。他们有成本，我相信是1900万美元。所以那是5300万美元的利润，这是大多数《财富》500强公司都会嫉妒的利润率。
What happens at $53 million profit? Where does it go?
5300万美元利润发生了什么？它去哪儿了？
Well, it goes to fund the other 28 or 29 teams here at Penn State. The entire cost of these teams is carried by the revenue that the football team generates. Penn State is fortunate in that they're able to raise enough money to support athletics. At most schools in this country, they run an annual average deficit of maybe $8 million to $10 million a year.
好吧，它去资助宾夕法尼亚州立大学的其他28或29支球队。这些球队的全部成本由橄榄球队产生的收入承担。宾夕法尼亚州立大学很幸运，因为他们能够筹集足够的钱来支持体育运动。在这个国家的多数学校，他们每年平均运行大约800万到1000万美元的赤字。
You were saying that $53 million is the profit in a year from football at Penn State. How does that compare to Penn State budget? Like, is that a big chunk of it?
你刚才说5300万美元是宾夕法尼亚州立大学橄榄球一年的利润。这与宾夕法尼亚州立大学预算相比如何？比如，这是一个很大的部分吗？
Their overall budget for the school is probably like $4 billion.
他们学校的总预算可能像40亿美元。
It just doesn't seem like that much. Like, it doesn't seem like it would have that much influence.
看起来好像没那么多。比如，看起来它不会有那么大的影响力。
Well, what you've got to remember is that football and Joe Paterno are the face of this university. I mean, that's the marketing of your university. And you go around campus and look at the names of the buildings and the people that have donated money here, and they're either ex-football players, people who have somehow been associated with Joe over the years. So I mean, if you don't have a successful football team, if you don't have a team that's generating revenue and victories, you're quickly going to find yourself with decreased admissions, with lower contributions.
好吧，你必须记住的是，橄榄球和乔·帕特诺是这所大学的面孔。我的意思是，那是你大学的营销。你在校园里走走，看看建筑物名字和在这里捐钱的人，他们要么是前橄榄球运动员，要么是以某种方式多年来与乔联系在一起的人。所以我的意思是，如果你没有成功的橄榄球队，如果你没有产生收入和胜利的球队，你很快就会发现自己面临减少入学，减少贡献。
You think it's going to affect the school's finances that this has happened?
你认为这件事发生了会影响学校的财务吗？
I think that's the great fear. I mean, the fear is that if Penn State's image, the image they've sold to these donors and contributors all the years is this squeaky-clean image. And if that's tarnished, that's a lot of potential donations. I was just going back on some of my research I did when I was doing the series of stories about Penn State, and there were quite a few donors who at that time, said, when they had no inkling that anything like this was in the wind, said I'm more than happy to give my money to Penn State, because they do things the right way. If that ever changes, I'll have to make an assessment at that time.
我想那是巨大的恐惧。我的意思是，恐惧是如果宾夕法尼亚州立大学的形象，他们多年来卖给这些捐赠者和贡献者的形象是这种纯净无瑕的形象。如果那被玷污了，那就是很多潜在的捐赠。我刚回看了一些我在做关于宾夕法尼亚州立大学故事系列时所做的研究，当时有不少捐赠者说，当他们没有迹象表明有任何像这样的事在酝酿中时，说我非常乐意给宾夕法尼亚州立大学我的钱，因为他们做事的方式正确。如果那改变了，我届时必须做一个评估。
Wait, wait. They said if that ever changes, I think I'll have to look at it? People actually went that far?
等等，等等。他们说如果那改变了，我想我得看看它？人们竟然走那么远？
Yeah. I mean, because at that time, and for quite a while, people were wondering what this place is going to look like when Joe leaves. You know, Joe's sort of been the guy that's propped up this image. So you can imagine that that assessment is being made by hundreds of different people, even as we speak. Do I continue to give my money to Penn State, or do I want my name associated with something so sordid as this?
是的。我的意思是，因为在那个时候，并且有相当长一段时间，人们都在想当乔离开时这个地方会是什么样子。你知道，乔一直是支撑这个形象的人。所以你可以想象，即使我们说话时，数百个不同的人也在做那个评估。我是否继续给宾夕法尼亚州立大学我的钱，还是我想让我的名字与如此肮脏的东西联系在一起？
Frank Fitzpatrick of the Philadelphia Inquirer.
《费城问询报》的弗兰克·菲茨帕特里克。
Here is one more thing about how the fate of the football team affects everything in this town. This is another clip from our 2009 show. Nancy Updike, for that show, did this story about the local businesses at Penn State, in the town of State College. The week that we were there, nearly every business owner told us that their businesses were significantly down because of the football team. Because of Penn State's loss to Ohio State the week before. Anyway, this is from her story.
这是关于橄榄球队的命运如何影响这个镇上一切的另一件事。这是我们2009年节目的另一个片段。南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）为那个节目做了这个关于宾夕法尼亚州立大学当地企业的故事，在州立学院镇。我们在那里的那个星期，几乎每个企业主都告诉我们，由于橄榄球队，他们的生意大大下降。因为宾夕法尼亚州立大学上一周输给了俄亥俄州立大学。无论如何，这是她故事里的。
This is McLanahan's, a sprawling Hearst Castle of a store. It's your basic drugstore, deli produce market, hardware, underwear, beer pong, stationary, grocery, Penn State merchandise emporium, which over the years has acquired and absorbed the stores that used to be next to it, to the point where it's bought up everything it can, and the only way left to expand is to cram more stuff everywhere. And there's always something clamoring for more space.
这是McLanahan's，一家赫斯特城堡般的庞大商店。它是你的基本药店、熟食农产品市场、硬件、内衣、啤酒乒乓、文具、杂货、宾夕法尼亚州立大学商品商场，多年来它收购并吸收了它旁边的商店，到了它买下一切它能买的东西，唯一扩展的方法是往任何地方塞更多东西。而且总有什么东西在吵着要更多空间。
McLanahan's owner Ray Agostinelli says that over and over again, he's had to stock way up on some usually sleepy object that has suddenly become a crazy hot seller.
McLanahan's老板雷·阿戈斯蒂内利（Ray Agostinelli）说，一遍又一遍，他不得不囤积某种通常冷门的商品，而这些商品突然成了疯狂的热门商品。
Well, it happened one time with marshmallows, and all of a sudden, all the marshmallows were gone. And here, what it was, was that they'd take them to the football games, and they were throwing marshmallows.
好吧，有一次发生在棉花糖上，突然间，所有的棉花糖都没了。而这里，是他们带它们去橄榄球比赛，他们在扔棉花糖。
You said people were throwing marshmallows onto the field?
你说人们在往球场扔棉花糖？
Oh yeah, if they did-- They were? Getting pretty dangerous with them. This wasn't too good. And they got outlawed. But the kids would come in and buy all the marshmallows, and we said, wait a minute. We never sold that many marshmallows. What? But it's just whatever the crazes are, you have to keep up with and be there.
噢是的，如果他们做了……他们是在吗？用它们变得相当危险。这不太好。然后它们被取缔了。但孩子们会进来买光所有的棉花糖，我们说，等一下。我们从没卖出过那么多棉花糖。什么？但这只是无论狂热是什么，你都必须跟上并待在那里。
And then there are the crazes that never go away. Sex. One of McLanahan's many frank and nonjudgmental offerings is its display, right up front, that is condoms on top, lubricant in the middle, pregnancy tests on the bottom.
然后有永不消失的狂热。性。McLanahan's的许多坦率和非评判性的产品之一是它的展示，就在最前面，那是上面的避孕套，中间的润滑剂，底部的验孕棒。
Ray takes me into the two Penn State merchandise sections of the store. It's a full sensory experience. That's a CD of the school's band in the background. There are seven different kinds of car air fresheners with the Penn State logo, pacifiers, a steering wheel cover.
雷带我进了商店的两个宾夕法尼亚州立大学商品区。这是一种完整的感官体验。背景中那是学校乐队的CD。有七种不同种类的车用空气清新剂带有宾夕法尼亚州立大学标志，安抚奶嘴，方向盘套。
Ray, are you ever amazed at something you never knew that Penn State logo could be put on it? I just saw a remote control, a TV remote--
雷，你有没有对某种你从未知道宾夕法尼亚州立大学标志可以放在上面的东西感到惊讶？我刚刚看到一个遥控器，电视遥控器——
You put it on here and it'll sell. You put it on your microphone, it'll sell.
你把它放在这里，它就会卖。你把它放在你的麦克风上，它就会卖。
In the almost 50 years Ray has been working at McLanahan's-- he bought it from Bob McLanahan 40 years ago-- Ray has seen the Penn State merchandise in his store go from almost an afterthought, maybe one rack of sweatshirts, to being a third of his business. The only downside is--
在雷在McLanahan's工作近50年里——他40年前从鲍勃·麦克拉纳汉（Bob McLanahan）那里买下了它——雷看到他店里的宾夕法尼亚州立大学商品从几乎是一个事后想法，也许是一架连帽衫，变成了他生意的一三分之一。唯一负面的是——
If Penn State would have a losing season, sales would drop dramatically.
如果宾夕法尼亚州立大学有一个输球的赛季，销售额会急剧下降。
Oh, is that true?
哦，那是真的吗？
Oh my gosh. You can't imagine.
噢天哪。你无法想象。
Ray says if Penn State loses one football game, sales of Penn State merch at McLanahan's go down 20%. Not for a day, for a week, and sometimes even longer, until the next winning game.
雷说如果宾夕法尼亚州立大学输掉一场橄榄球比赛，McLanahan's的宾夕法尼亚州立大学商品销售额会下降20%。不是一天，是一周，有时甚至更长，直到下一场获胜的比赛。
OK. There's more to that story, but you'll have to go online. That was Nancy Updike.
好的。那个故事还有更多，但你必须上网。那是南希·厄普代克。
Let's end this hour at a game. Right? A football game. I went to a game when we were there in 2009 with two juniors, Megan Koch and Zach Fliegel. Megan's Nittany Lion memories include the night of her high school homecoming, which also happen to be the night of the 2005 Michigan game. She was all dressed up. Her dad was on the cell phone.
让我们在比赛中结束这一小时。对吧？橄榄球比赛。我们2009年在那儿的时候，我和两个大三学生，梅根·科赫（Megan Koch）和扎克·弗利格尔（Zach Fliegel）去看了比赛。梅根的尼塔尼雄狮（Nittany Lion）回忆包括她高中返校节的那个晚上，那天晚上正好也是2005年密歇根比赛的晚上。她打扮得很漂亮。她爸爸在手机上。
He was calling me, telling me, play by play, what was going on. So I remember I go inside, and my field hockey team always gets together in like a hallway. And all the parents come around, everyone comes around and we get pictures taken. And I remember my dad called me, and he's like, you're not going to believe this, but Michigan just scored and we lost with two seconds left on the clock. And I remember I just hung up the phone, and I was like, oh my gosh. I started like crying. And one of the hockey moms came up to me, and she was like, Megan, what's wrong, you know? And I was like, Penn State just lost. And she was-- she laughed. And I have never been so close to punching a parent.
他给我打电话，告诉我，一球一球地，正在发生什么。所以我记得我进去，我的曲棍球队总是在像走廊里的地方聚在一起。所有的父母都过来了，每个人都过来了，我们拍了照片。我记得我爸爸给我打电话，他就像，你不会相信这个，但密歇根刚得分，我们在时钟还剩两秒时输了。我记得我只是挂了电话，就像，噢天哪。我开始像是哭了起来。其中一个曲棍球妈妈向我走过来，她就像，梅根，你怎么了，你知道吗？我说，宾夕法尼亚州立大学刚输了。她就是……她笑了。我从来没有那么接近去打一个家长。
Zach also has childhood memories of Penn State games. On our way to the stadium, we pass some little boys in the tailgate, tossing around a football.
扎克也有关于宾夕法尼亚州立大学比赛的童年记忆。在去体育场的路上，我们经过一些尾门派对里的小男孩，正在投掷橄榄球。
I used to be that kid, throwing the football around in between cars and stuff.
我过去就是那个孩子，在车子中间之类的扔橄榄球。
The Lions played, the Lions won. It was the last home game of the year, and seniors down in the first row were crying. Zach said even a bad game, being in the stadium, in the student section, was worth it.
雄狮队打比赛，雄狮队赢了。那是那一年的最后一场主场比赛，坐在第一排的老年人都在哭。扎克说即使是一场糟糕的比赛，在体育场里，在学生区，也是值得的。
I live for this. I'll probably be coming here until I'm old and wrinkled.
我为这个而活。我可能直到我老得满脸皱纹都会来这里。
Really? So like, 50 years from now, where will you be sitting? Point to the spot.
真的吗？所以50年后，你会坐在哪里？指指那个点。
Right over there. Hopefully in WC, WD on the 30, 40 yard line, maybe.
就在那边。希望在WC，WD在30，40码线上，可能。
Show me the seats where you want?
给我看你想坐的座位？
And he pointed a third of the way up, 30 yard line. I went around to his friends in the student section. Nobody hesitated. 50 yard line, skybox, 30 yard line. They all wanted to come back.
他指了三分之一处，30码线。我转到了学生区他的朋友那里。没有人犹豫。50码线，豪华包厢，30码线。他们都想回来。
Then when I emailed Zach this week, and asked if he still thought he'd be back in the year 2059, he said it depends on how the school handles the charges in the next few months.
当我本周给扎克发邮件，问他是否还认为他会在2059年回来时，他说这取决于学校在未来几个月如何处理这些指控。
["WE ARE PENN STATE" CHANT]
[高呼“我们是宾夕法尼亚州立大学”]
Well, our program today was produced by Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Miki Meek and me, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Jane Feltes, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Aaron Scott, Alissa Shipp, Brian Reed, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder, Seth Lind is our production manager, Emily Condon is our office manager.
好吧，我们今天的节目是由莎拉·柯尼格，乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar），米基·米克（Miki Meek）和我制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg），本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun），简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes），丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak），罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien），亚伦·斯科特（Aaron Scott），阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp），布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder），塞思·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的制作经理，艾米莉·康登（Emily Condon）是我们的办公室经理。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, where you can hear our original 2009 show about Penn State, "Number One Party School," for absolutely free, or you can hear any other show we have ever made, our download our apps, or do all kinds of stuff, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，在那里你可以免费听到我们2009年关于宾夕法尼亚州立大学的原始节目，“第一派对学校”，或者你可以听到我们制作过的任何其他节目，下载我们的应用，或者做各种各样的事情，thisamericanlife.org。《This American Life》由公共广播国际公司发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金来源致谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who kept holding his personnel conferences at a big boy restaurant near the highway-- I know!-- until--
WBEZ管理对我们节目的监督由我们的老板，托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生，他一直坚持在高速公路附近的一家大男孩餐厅举行他的人事会议——我知道！——直到——
They had a big boy meeting, and they sat him down, they had a sit-down, and they said-- you're not going to do this again, right?
他们开了一个大男孩会议，让他坐下来，进行了一次谈话，说……你不能再这样做了，对吧？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着《This American Life》的更多故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际公司。
Next week in the podcast of This American Life. There's this children's book, a real one, called Nobody's Family is Going to Change. That is an oddly menacing title, if you ask me. Nobody's Family is Going to Change. It is a thought that occurs to you when you go home for Thanksgiving or Christmas, for sure. We try to figure out whether it's true. Next week on the podcast or on your local Public Radio station.
下周在《This American Life》的播客中。有这本儿童书，一本真正的书，叫《没人家的家庭会改变》（Nobody's Family is Going to Change）。如果你问我，那是一个奇怪的威胁性标题。《没人家的家庭会改变》。当你回家过感恩节或圣诞节时，这确实是一个出现在你脑海中的想法。我们尝试弄清楚它是否是真的。下周在播客上或在你的当地公共广播电台。